if you need a reason to start playing
pokemon go again the next update just
might do the trick I'm Tony and this is
your bonus game spot news update Pokemon
go is adding daily bonuses but that
doesn't mean you can just log in and get
free stuff instead you'll have to
complete challenges like visiting a
pokey stop or catching a Pokemon the
more consistent you are the better
rewards you'll earn Stardust and XP will
be your main prizes but if you complete
challenges seven days in a row you'll
get yourself even more bonus items if
you've already been playing the game
consistently just keep doing what you're
doing for some extra prizes there's no
set release date for this update but
developer niantic said it'll arrive
quote soon this is one of many updates
that have come to pokemon go so don't be
surprised if we hear about another in
the near future maybe we'll finally be
able to trade after the next one for all
the biggest pokemon news you're already
in the right place
you